uh we're going to talk today about the
uh what we call the emergent economic
engine uh where we try to understand the
economic impact of the crisis
so today we're going to talk uh i hope
you can see
the slides otherwise somebody needs to
shout at me
we're going to talk to today a little
bit of what we do what the emerging
alliance actually is
then we're going to talk about two tools
which are also available in github
one is we call the cookie cutter and i'm
gonna present that
and i'm gonna hand over to my colleague
from ibm
uh alvaro uh so i'm rolls royce naval
with ibm
um and then he's gonna talk about the
economic the emerging economic engine
which is a simulation model so what is
the uh emerging alliance
um well back in in mid-march when when
we all
saw that there is this pandemic outbreak
uh we all wondered what to do and
because we're all based in in big
corporates uh
one of the initial thinking was like is
to do with plan ability with what what
is the future going to bring and
this sparked the idea and lots of people
look are you looking into the health
side of things
is there anything that we can do to
improve the planability like how
how long will things take and what will
be the impact onto the economy
with this pandemia which is a first of a
kind experience for definitely for me
and probably for most of us
so um it's uh it's an alliance of
people's not-for-profit organization
registered in the uk where
actually lots of uh corporates are
joining so two of them ibm rolls-royce
are presenting today
there is other contributors there's a
web page out there which are also going
to bring up
at the end of uh this presentation
so who are we uh even though we are big
corporate
uh uh players we we actually
was the first time they've actually
started to collaborate and it was a
fascinating experience it was
really really interesting really very
exciting to do that
so we shared a common passion for data
we shared a common vision around being
able to
do some good uh to understand what the
pandemia actually
is and this matters a lot to uh big
corporates of course we we actually are
working agile so we do
uh trial and error we fail for us we
fail hard and then we're just gonna
get up again and continue uh after we've
learned our lessons i'm gonna talk
quickly about the scope of work that our
team has been doing
since around about mid-may of this year
we had a number of work streams uh that
we we tried to cover the whole area
around uh the coveted pandemia so
this was uh first piece of work which uh
obviously has to take into account the
health situation so this is
the predicting of a risk index for
certain areas currently we do that for
uk germany france italy and also south
korea
um second thing i'm gonna talk today is
about the
uh generation of a library this will be
cookie cutter
and last but not least we plan to do
something that can be used for what-if
modeling for wave three-way
four in 2021 uh to better understand
roughly when these waves could hit us
how long they might take
and what the consequences would be on
the economy
so a few dashboards that we build these
dashboards are not available to the
public
anyone we also accept citizen data
scientists or individuals to sign up on
the merchant alliance
if they want to be part of the
undertaking
then you could get access to the
cloud pack for data tool which is
provided provisioned by
ibm which is essentially a set of uh
jupyter notebooks running on a
kubernetes cluster and so much more
on this tool set underneath the uh ibm
advertisement to
to alvaro he feels inclined to do so any
other so this is all uh cognos
dashboards that you set up
uh one of them is obviously the emergent
risk index
uh that's very similar to your cognos
dashboards but it does
to your default copy dashboards but it
does take into account
more factors than just the infection
numbers it also takes into account like
hospital beds availability that kind of
thing so it's really much more of a
risky index
we also do have some limited predictive
capability together with an
understanding of
where these weights where these
contributions for the prediction comes
from so it's about explainable
machine learning explainable ai not just
throw numbers over the fence
and assume they're good so this is the
dashboard on the upper right hand side
we obviously look into lockdown measures
there's a wonderful data set from
oxford university there and in order to
understand
fly forward capabilities we have started
to cluster these
government measures so it's there
similarities between
uh various governments undertaking
certain lockdown measures can you
compare one country to the other
or is every single com country
completely different
this matters a lot if you want to do fly
forwards what if modeling
like how many scenarios would you need
to take into account how many countries
react in how many different ways going
forward
other pieces of work that we've done has
more to do with uh
natural text processing in the broader
sense so one had to do with sentiment
analysis of news
around kovit another one is because
werewolves voice
had to do with understanding flight
limitations can you actually travel from
point a to point b
and return you may recall that la uh in
the summer
uh all of a sudden the uk issued a uh
quarantine warning for for tourists
traveling back from spain into the uk so
it's not just good enough to be able to
travel from the uk into spain but also
you
have to be able to come back without
having to undergo
measures obviously we are in the
aerospace industry so we are
pretty much hit hard by the pandemic
effects of course so this
one of our interests and adjacent to
that as we also started looking at
public data open data available from
airbnb or second source around airbnb to
understand how to demand
onto the
accommodation industry has changed so
some of the dashboards that we have
produced there
is around topics and sentiments so
it's about how frequent these topics are
then you've got sentiment analysis are
they positive or negative
so it's not just about more news around
airlines being produced but also is this
positive news or negative news what's
the tone of it
and this is all laying out this
analysis of certain news sources for the
second quarter
when we had data available for it for
the regional risk we also have the
notion of neighborhood
relationships so we understand how
countries hang together how states are
decomposed so how countries are
decomposed into states and then states
into regions
so we also understand the progression
how these things belong to each other
country restrictions i was alluding to
before we've got dashboards where you
can select a country and then you can
find
out can i select from can i fly from
germany
to chile and can i return from chidi
back to germany without going into
quarantine
this is using what's called no tams
notice to airmen
this is sort of almost publicly
available data or there's public data
sources for that
this is pretty much how pilots uh who
have the ultimate ultimate say whether
you're allowed to board an airplane or
not
how they're being advised of the current
legal situations and last but not least
uh the uh airbnb where we looked at
how the overnight stays for airbnb
uh trips has changed geographically we
found that it's more on the outskirts
and less on the center of the cities but
also
that kind of timeline you see there with
these humps
this is showing the evolution of
bookings so the green line would have
been what
we we would have predicted for airbnb to
make business and the
amber line is what actually happened uh
when it comes into bookings
so that's giving you a bit of a summary
overview and i was talking about
now these two tools we're gonna hone in
on
today one we call the cookie cutter and
i'm going to talk a bit about that
and fingers crossed so far everything is
still working i'll give you a live demo
of how
it looks like so what is it what problem
are we trying to solve
um we are as i said when we set off uh
with the american alliance the idea was
we try to give an answer like how
how long will things take how long will
the second
wave or the first wave take and right
now i think everybody has that on his
mind like how long will the lockdown
measures take and what's going to happen
next so if you work with time series
data
and you want to do some kind of
prediction it's always a best practice
to take the data you already have which
is looking
back in the past and try to then find
out what happened in the past so cookie
cutter is trying to give you some kind
of view and editor
where you can look back at individual
countries uh health situation and then
mark it up label it and save it so he
can base anything
on on his outputs cookie cutter is also
doing a second aspect we're going to
talk
a little bit about in a second because
we want to predict the
impact of the kobe situation onto
economy
we had real problems in finding data
sources they would directly relate to
what is the impact of
onto the economy due to copyright
effects so
it's like a data editor where you can
sort of draw your own lines
your own graphs through the rather
jiggly and incomplete data that you have
available if
you try to find out what the impact
actually is
without doing powerpoint battles let me
just hop over now to
the actual tool
so uh cookie cutter is implemented in
python
uh i'm a big fan of bookie and bookish
server so i had to choose spoken server
for that because then
it's really straightforward to deploy
almost straightaway uh python code onto
web browsers and share it with others so
it's a nice
server client application so the way it
works is
as you as you load the data is you can
select from a number of data sources
which
have been implemented so far so you can
choose the good old
widely known johns hopkins global data
source and then
you can choose which country you want to
look at let's have a look at austria
as an example it then gives you the
number of cases at the top end
uh which is the number of cases were
reported it gives a
drop a drop back of a rather crudely
changed point detector based
uh classification of whether a region
would be a wave
or a period of calm you can tell
that there is no clear definition of
what a wave is and what a period of calm
is
actually it's quite of a headache which
is also why you want to have that kind
of human in the loop data labeling
so that humans can lay an echo and say
okay what i want to do i want to
save this one i want to call this one
now i call this austria wave one
and i'm gonna save the data and it'll be
saved in a data store in a database
actually so i can later then use that
to do whatever kind of derivations of uh
recycling the wave one data from austria
for
a wave two model for austria or wastely
model for brazil
if that's what i want to do below that
you see another prominent data source
and that is
just two views of a really interesting
thing that has to do with government
lockdown measures
it's the oxford cgrt data set
this is listing for practically all
countries on the planet
what governments have been undertaken
it's breaking it out by various read
uh dimensions like where the schools
have been closed when it has limitations
on travel etc
so what you see here is the individual
steps in that case austria has been
doing so austria
started to close the workplaces around
about here uh sort of
towards the end of march 2020 and
the data is updated probably every week
that may happen anytime
soon again so what you see here that
how long this measure was put in place
the data up here is in a numerical
representation of that so oxford went
through a lot of effort in condensing
summing up these data into one numerical
measure between 0 and 100 100 being
the most extreme government measures
that you can think of
and typically heavy lockdown numbers are
around about in the 80s
which is what we see a lot now these
days again
so if you if you select that and save
that it will also save
select and save the other portions of
the oxford data set
below that is another piece of work that
was done by
an ibm colleague in holland darmian
switzerland and damian is applying
gumball
distribution fits to these infection
curves so we all
heard a lot about sir modeling and
whatever derivations you've got
from srr modeling as well darmian
found out that a gumball distribution
actually quite nicely fits
a lot of these waves in a really
convenient way
so this is fitting now various curves uh
over each other
and what you see here the the red pluses
the dots here this is sort of the smooth
trend from the actual infection numbers
this same number as here so it's a d
seasoned number and this is the
resulting curve from damian's model
there's a bit of functionality missing
on that tool you can
sort of turn off some of these curve
fits
and then sort of remove them from the
equation
if you don't like uh these curve sets
and what's missing is that number should
be changing but
uh it's almost finished you can always
say
these things um last but not least uh
this
reminds you of the votes you've been
undertaking before so you don't have to
re-vote
too many times and here now is something
that i found really really interesting
and exciting
this is now me voting on
the world more or less uh more that in a
second uh
four periods of waste and piece of calms
and this is now providing you a little
bit of
insight into how long a wave actually
would take
this is me voting so it's not a
scientific definition it's good i'm an
engineer by background so i'm not a
doctor
i've got limited knowledge of
epidemiology
but for my voting is now i see this kind
of distribution
for the duration of waves that i have
observed and again more than that in a
second
what you find out that you got sort of
you take personal distributions that
ways typically take between
40 and 70 80 days roundabout
um period of calm are have a different
distribution as they're not as
pronounced so somewhere between 50
and 150 days the interesting thing is
over there i found
what's plotted here is the relative peak
of new cases so how many people got
infected divided by
100 000 of population
and how long these periods take and what
you see here so this is the duration of
the peak and this is
how high it was how many people got
infected
and to my big surprise and this is also
coming out from the gumball distribution
by the way
is that the duration of a wave is almost
independent from
how many people get infected that's
really really interesting
uh let's just have a look at that
whether i just made this up or not
uh let's just look at
ireland so ireland just went through a
second wave which was slightly higher
than the first wave and if you look at
that low and behold depends on how you
know call
and what a wave is and how what you want
to mark uh
the the numbers are actually somehow
different even though the second wave is
slightly higher
uh seeing is believing let's have a look
at
countries like israel
where again you see a very similar
behavior again it's very subjective it's
humans labeling these things but uh the
the wave one of israel took that long
and wave two of the draw starting point
here took probably
as long as wave wave one which is a
really interesting phenomenon uh this
has to do
uh that would take longer and a lot of
speculation on mines my understanding
is the sizes of these how these social
networks that can affect each other how
the sizes are
how many how big a number you actually
are able to interact with
and uh also the change in behavior by
people
as they learn that something is
happening and then they will naturally
start to self-isolate because bad things
are happening on the outside
but this is an interesting thing now be
mindful that
the labeling that i've done that i just
showed does not apply
for these kind of big waves because you
can't make out
these waves in these big nations it all
seems to be a big
mesh of something which is another
interesting insight of course
because uh it starts making sense if you
start decomposing
the nationwide ways into uh
statewide ways so obviously uh new york
had a very pronounced wave
earlier this year so it's an interesting
thing that
looking at ways at a nation level may
not make sense because ways are very
local events
and you probably have to find out what
the right level of
abstraction is in order to make out how
long such an infection wave actually
takes
this is also why overlaying this with
these gumball distributions i found very
useful because you do see an awful lot
of these
uh waves that are just one after the
other and they're all rather compact but
they all
are having similar durations which i
find really really amazing
another bit uh just for the sake of it
you see that a lot
in some of the data sets you always see
this these blips
around here so you see those blips
around there so
this is just looking at data uh and
let's just look at
some of these as you always see these
small blips i can also look at that
in the uh sorry look at that
you see that an awful lot uh also in uh
in uh in europe uh you always see these
tiny blips around uh summer
so at the time most people were thinking
uh
that these blips were due to an
increased testing of people returning
from a holiday but now in hindsight this
is why i love
uh we enjoy looking at these uh
the data in hindsight in hindsight these
were probably all very small waves very
local but
uh they must have been around so you see
always these
tiny waves there uh it was probably some
kind of small wave
uh and this has to do it always happens
around august this
time frame towards the end of summer
holidays so
uh again this is just uh i'm speculating
a bit but this is uh i'm not
it's just a data talking so that's one
aspect and the rest is just usability
uh there's going to be a readme out
there which i'm
definitely trying to update so this is
trying to the purpose that we're trying
to do is try to capture wave one
calm one wave two data for various
nations such we begin to understand what
happens how how long the space takes how
high they are
what the government measures were were
active when this wave happened so that's
one key
thing if you want to model out say 2021
that's one key aspect second aspect you
need
is how the economy reacts to that
uh said before and this is now required
for the next model that alvaro is going
to talk a bit about
before we try to understand again i
think everybody has a kind of question
in their head like what's going to
happen to restaurants what's going to
happen to
uh tourism uh all kinds of industries
around
event management and all these things so
we try to be data driven so obviously we
were looking around an awful lot for
data sources
and as i mentioned before some of those
data sources they come in
very very late like gdp numbers come in
like almost two months
after the end of the quarter um
so in order to bridge that gap but also
because the data was very jiggly
i found that trying to smooth the heck
out of it by applying all kinds of
filters and whatever
it's just as useful to just have a
graphical editor so this is the second
part of cookie
cutter you can sort of capture you can
load relevant
uh economic data and then
by just using a cursor you can just draw
your own line through it so
we look at here is a data set from the
transport
safety authority in the us which is
telling us the number of passengers
through safety
checks in in the us and the purpose of
cookie cutter here is now to have
some kind of data editor where you can
just choose
a reference data set and just put your
own curve through it
and you're going to see in a moment why
these red numbers are
where these red dots are labeled red
that's the sort of the shock to the
economy and why the green ones are
labeled green that's sort of the
recovery
but that's sort of then you begin to
understand
how deep the impact has been on in that
case aerospace and yes it has been
that deep so aerospace business
collapsed to
levels like that now you can now load
multiple data sets so let's just overlay
that with
uh say euro control uh this is the
number of flights in europe
uh uh measured so it's just a number of
flights it's not the passengers
data before was passengers and you can
just now start playing with the data so
maybe
you you know think okay maybe i was too
conservative here and that always
happens on the demo right
uh come on just be gentle to me
it's not the world's best most
user-friendly editor i should say
but uh and then maybe you just want to
change that curve and maybe you just
want to put these numbers
somewhere else and and just see whether
this all makes sense so this is sort of
the
idea for that because smoothing is so
hard because the data sets are so
different
um so there is for example things around
gdp that i mentioned before it has a
completely different envelope
uh and and whatever can be quite
confusing and because i could uh i
finally also found my
my most uh favorite uh data set
which we were all wanting to have which
is the toilet paper sales uh earlier
this year
so uh again this is now swinging up but
uh
it's unfortunately incomplete i don't
know how it progresses uh progress for
the remainder of the year but there's a
wonderful data set out there we can also
look at uh i think it was
was a pizza on there let's just look at
that let's see what happened here oh wow
that's an interesting uh east uh
yeah that collapsed so anyhow so there's
lots of datasets out there the way it's
been deployed
is that this is a dockerizable container
which you can deploy which comes with
its own sql database and a set of
notebooks where you can download these
data
so you can refresh it and this tool is
trying to answer the question and like
what was the impact on to the economy
in the absence of actual accurate data
where you need to apply
some kind of engineering understanding
and how to actually do that
um that was the end of my part i just
got to pass over now hand over to
alvaro who's going to talk to you about
the second tool
yeah um well thank you klaus um let me
share my screen now
okay hopefully you can see my screen
so um yeah um i want to talk about the
the emergent economic engine so um um
by the way i'm i'm already i'm a data
scientist at ibm
and well i have a background in
economics and that's perhaps why
i was working on this part of the
project um
so really the idea the idea behind the
emergent economic engine it was to
to try to understand how uh the pandemic
had affected uh
had affected um the different sectors of
the economy
and the reason is that as everybody
knows these days uh
not all the sectors of the economy was
were affected in the same way
so there were sectors like a transporter
like accommodation that went uh
down basically by a hundred percent or
ninety percent whereas other sectors
didn't really suffer that much
so uh coming from that understanding of
the reality we wanted to kind of
see uh we wanted to kind of model how uh
how one shocked one sector of the
economy would propagate
throughout the rest of the sectors of
the economy um
depending on how connected this sector
was with the rest of the network
uh to do that we used uh we used uh what
is called in economics
leontief input output model and the
basic idea behind this model
is that um all sectors of the economy
are connected through input output
linkages
so what's an input output linkage well
the idea behind an input output linkage
is that what one sector of the economy
produces
is consumed by another sector of the
economy
so when you generalize this idea to the
whole economy then you get
some sort of network where everything is
connected with everything
and then from there you can just switch
off one one sector of the economy and
see what happens with the rest
um this kevin product model was uh
it's kind of a very well known model in
in economics these days but uh it wasn't
suitable for our
k and for our case uh uh for one reason
or it wasn't uh it wasn't suitable
as it was in theory for one reason is
that
uh it didn't give us a time kind of view
of the world
and we wanted to understand how shocks
propagated in time as well
um so we implemented a kind of a
a more developed version uh based on
literature as well on existing
literature
where um that is defined in in this
equation here
which is basically telling us that the
change
in the the change in uh input
uh or or sorry on of the output of an
economy
is a function of uh of uh certain
economic shocks
the change in time and also saturn
counter shocks
um when you think about the shocks
it would be basically um perhaps your
understanding of how the
economy is is falling these days or how
particular sector has been affected
it could also come from cookie cutter
from the second functionality that klaus
mentioned
and then the count of shock even though
it's a it's kind of
mathematically a similar thing would be
a different a different
concept it would be how how an economy
is affected by
a government deciding to kind of uh pump
money
into certain sectors in particular and
then we're left with this
with this factor here with this
component which is the input output
coefficients
so uh perhaps not surprisingly and
because economists are not very
imaginative the
legend of input output model uses um
uses one kind of
very very essential type of data which
is called
input output tables so what an input
output table is
this flow this flow representation of
the economy that i just talked about so
what one sector produces is consumed by
another sector
uh you have uh you have some sort of a
schematic version of of uh
this this type of data in in this chart
here
in this case it's coming from the oecd
that produces input tables from uh
for uh lots of different countries but
you could also have it for for specific
countries in such as the uk and you also
have spain the us
and most most of the countries in the
in the western world um so this is like
the
theoretical framework that we that we
develop
but obviously things are not just like
that
we also have uh we also have the
emergent economic engine itself which is
uh which is an app that we developed to
kind of
generalize the idea of transmitting
shocks propagating them through
throughout the
economic network the basic idea behind
the
emergent economic engine is to play with
the
with the two uh shock parameters or the
shock and counter shock parameters of of
our model
and to kind of simulate different
scenarios depending on what your belief
or your or your understanding of the of
the economy is
so uh we have divided them in two levels
basically liver one relates to the shock
and liberty relates to the counter shock
so in the case of lever one you can
choose your shock profile that can come
from
from cookie cutter from your
understanding and
the app will give you how much output
changes
for a for a given shot and then in liver
two
you can say okay uh i don't want my
economy to fall this much so i'm gonna
i'm gonna pump resources into it and i'm
going to um
i'm going to try to counter-measure the
shock that i am
that it is suffering i'm going to show
you a demo
um i'm not sure your demo now because
it's not obviously not that
i don't want to kill you by we're just
showing you slides um
just so you know the code is on github
and you also have a
beta version uh deployed at the moment
so you can also play with it if you want
and um without further ado let me show
you the
the app um so this is like
this is basically the um this is the
home page of the
the emergent economic engine actually
i'm gonna refresh because i was testing
it
for the presentation um
here we're using the the uk the uk input
output tables um
you can we're gonna we're gonna make
available other input tables as well
such as the us uh oecd um
i think we also have germany but really
you can you can take it from
basically everywhere um like really like
statistical offices around the world
produce these tables
um so yeah let's uh let's play the
simulation let's say that we want to run
this simulation for eight years
um and then uh we're gonna this is a bit
of a technical concept um but
let's say that we want to propagate a
shock to the economy upstream
so this means that it's going to go
upstream the supply chain of all the
sectors that we shock
it can also go downstream but the
results are will be very similar
and then let's say that uh for a period
of uh
12 months all the sectors of the economy
stop producing about 10 of the regular
of the regular output so this means that
uh
perhaps uh because people cannot kind of
work
from their workplaces or they have to
work from home or some people cannot
even go to work
all sectors have to stop producing by 10
for 1d
and then let's say that uh there are
certain there's a particular sector that
actually
is uh shocked by more than that so ai
transport
cloud x cloud showed fell considerably
more than
10 let's say it's about 75
for also 12 months
so what you see in this chart is
basically how the shocks have propagated
throughout the whole youth of the uk
economy
so each line is a sector of the economy
and as you can see
not once not two sectors are the same so
because sectors are connected
differently with each other
then even though all of them initially
were set to fall 10
because one sector is going to be more
connected than than the rest
then it's going to fall more so for
instance whole trade is connected with a
wider rate a wide array of um
sectors in the economy so it falls by
more and
similarly with financial services and so
on which fall more than
other like uh imputed uh brands of
foreign architectures
um the whole idea is that uh there is a
diversity there is a
there is a kind of there's a wealth of
reactions to just
one particular economic shock you can
also see uh
sectors in particular you can also
compare um a couple of sectors and
um whichever you are you are most uh
interested about and um and the tool
will also show you
how much the economy falls for this uh
eight years that we are simulating so in
this case it will be
uh 20 which means that if you don't do
anything
for eight years this shock will be felt
uh quite substantially
and the economy will fall by 20 and this
is a summary
of uh of how much each sector will fall
in total
but as you probably remember there were
two levers
in this uh in this tool and the second
lever is really optional and i
made it optional because well you don't
need to pump any money into the economy
although perhaps you you probably want
in most of cases if you're a government
so let's say that you have a pool of
resources
and you want to and you just want the
economy to fall by less
and in particular in this case since
we're talking about the uk
let's say that we're gonna introduce
about eight percent uh extra resources
to the economy for a period of five
months one month after the shock started
the reason why i choose these parameters
in particular is because they are very
similar to
to the kind of stimulus that the uk
government
passed um so by the end of
during the summer and what you see in
the
in this chart is that is the result of
your stimulus
so uh in the in the light line you see
the no intervention scenario this is how
much your economy will fall
if nothing happens if you just leave it
and don't stimulate it at all
and the light i'm sorry in the dark one
will be the economy
in the intervention scenario with so
with this kind of profile of
intervention as you can see
i mean we are not magicians and we don't
have all the resources in the world so
the economy is still false but it
obviously falls by less and it falls
and it recovers uh faster you can also
check
particular sectors let's say let's let's
look at air transport
obviously because air transport fell by
a lot it almost doesn't feel
the stimulus but then again you can also
target specific sectors when you
when you um design your your stimulus so
let's say that i want to give
the the air transport sector a subsidy
that is equivalent to
say 15 of its total production
uh for a period of 12 months um
you can also do that with the tool and
you will see the same result like again
output falls but it falls by less and
then the transfer sector recovers faster
um so this is really the tool um
let me go back to my to my presentation
um so if you're interested in the in the
emergent alliance uh
here's the here's the website here's a
link to the website uh
we have published a lot of uh blogs as
well on on our findings so i
really recommend you to to have a look
at them if you are interested
um you can also you can also contact the
emergent alliance
if you want uh like at the beginning
we're very happy to to uh engage with
citizen data scientists
so uh please contact us if you want and
we also have a github repo so
if you are interested in what we have
talked about or
um today you can go to the repo and
please own it and or you can give us and
give us
a feedback on what you think and yeah
and
maybe just enjoy enjoy exploring it
so uh that's uh that's all on my site
and yeah i hope you
you enjoy it and yeah i guess we can
open the discussion to
questions
great thank you
do we have any question
yeah so hey
all right yes uh i have a
three question uh the first two are for
clause
uh yeah very interesting data analysis
uh and when you were talking about
duration of a wave
uh i had a question about that did you
also check
how the duration of a wave change in
time
so if i index each wave and if i go
through
each of these waves how does the
duration of a wave change
unfortunately there is um it's a good
question so
it's a bit of a fractal problems i'm
still struggling to find out what is the
right size of a country entity to
actually find a way
so for example i think that exam in
berlin things like uh
like north koreans or a level below the
city where you get probably a quarter of
a million ish people
quarter million and a half a million
people seems to be a reasonable size
anything below that
uh the number of infected people
is because integers and you know
increments of one
uh the numbers are not your friends so
mathematics numerics don't help you
anything above that you've got these
multiple ways so i still haven't
finished that but i said on
the course picture it seems to be
very very similar and it seems to be
almost independent
of uh the waste level keep that in mind
from a
nation point of view there's only so
many nations who've been going through a
clear wave too
so it's ireland israel uh
australia which had a slightly different
setup japan
and two or three more i think holland
and belgium are sort of going
through that wave as well we're a bit
unfortunate if you want to actually be
data driven unfortunately you have to
wait for the first of a kind events
to happen and then for a few of them
before you have any statistical
significance but as a to my big surprise
fact that a second wave is three four
five times stronger like it was in
israel than the first one
didn't change uh the the duration of it
it might have just extended it just a
little bit but
not nowhere near just to 110 percent
probably of the wave one
was practically uh uh independent
and the second one was about mortality
rate i don't know if you look at the
data
but i wonder uh if the mortality rate
between the veins are damped because in
biology there is a saying that the virus
reduces its mortality rate because it
wants to survive himself for itself
uh i wonder if you check that so
uh we had the original so that
is unfortunately in our case now the
data sources weren't our friend
uh you could derive mortality rate from
johns hopkins data because
hopkins have a mortality or recovery
together with the time stamp because i
also ingested rki
data in germany rki for some strange
reason they only
publish they don't publish timestamp
with the event
of with a mortality event they just they
have a line list for each patient more
or less
and all they do is they just say this
patient has a disease
and there's no time stamp so
unfortunately from rki don't ask me why
you can't compute mortality over time
you can only compute total mortality and
sort of it's
not even its evolution over time because
the the complete
when people have recovered or not so it
could be brought back
so you could take uh you could look at
the
data out of cookie cutter which is just
a begin and an end date really
and then fold it onto data sources we
should have that kind of information but
unfortunately because i wanted to
integrate this data source into one
editor
i had to cut down on on both recovered
and
deceased numbers
it would be very interesting because we
all know i think mortality could be
is probably more of
a social function on which country
is affected that kind of stuff then
and then there's different strands of
viruses at least there were initially i
haven't followed them recently
but i haven't exploited that that's a
good point maybe just compare that
this question was motivated by just an
observation in the website of morgan
post
and they have this mortality rate
as a function of time and i was saying
although germany has this second
wave but the mortality magnitude was not
changed
uh that was so that that comes from that
observation and i have one last question
to alvaro
um uh in the model in this
audi that you had uh
uh you had some parameters right
i couldn't completely follow uh all of
them
uh but uh did you find some combinations
that
uh that generates an interesting output
uh so but in other words did you
run some optimization for which
parameters you can i don't know
get uh i don't get uh
a positive output over time maybe let me
let me share my screen again
um so
um so so this this is the equation that
you're talking about right
um really so the the
the parameters of the equation are
actually given by
uh by theory so so you've got this a
which comes from the input output table
yeah they put up the tables
and um it's uh it's um
it comes from what the data from the
national
statistical office of the country that
you are downloading the input tables
from so
um it's just a transformation but it's a
magic operation there's no optimization
there or anything
so uh in a way you are you have to
believe
you have to believe that the economic
model is representing the reality well
and that
this input output these input tables are
already
showing you the reality so there is
really no optimization behind it
and in terms of the policy because you
had also this
when i talked about toronto i mean that
policy that you had this government
policy
uh in in your simulation uh
when when you are playing with that i
don't know variable the policy
did you find certain regions where
uh you get i don't know positive output
or a desirable
outcome so the desirable
the desirable outcome really depends on
what uh on what the
tool believes is a desirable outcome so
the user of the tool can be a um
can be a public authority such as the
government and
perhaps what the government wants was to
is not to kind of
lose jobs in one particular sector in
which case
you may you may want to you may want to
pump
resources into that sector or sectors
beside
besides so maybe it's very difficult to
for instance give money to two big
airlines
but it may make sense if you want to
save the whole tourism industry of your
country
so because these these sectors are very
very well connected
you you may want to give money to to the
airlines
so um what i found very very interesting
is precisely these these links are are
quite clear in the model when you
when you play with um with uh this with
saturn sectors such as the air transport
sector
it really so basically if the air
transfer sector falls by a lot
then tourism and travel agencies
are gonna are gonna fall as well a lot
so uh really the desirable part is
something that you define as a user
but uh but there is clearly certain
links that are
very worthwhile exploring as a user such
as this connection
yeah yeah i i think it's quite
interesting if you couple this
model with objective function so it
would be an
optimization optimal control so you can
see which policy would actually resolve
to a desirable
outcome that's uh that's a very good
point um actually um
we this is something we haven't
developed um yet
i would say but uh um then the world
talks about
about precisely this um you know control
theory and
and optimization
not
yeah
so here so it the kind of the network
relationship
is uh is given by the input output table
so
in this important table so here imagine
that we only have one country right
so in this row in in this row you have
the a productive sector so what what
this sector this industry one produces
and in each of the columns
you will have how much um how much
of the output of set of industry one is
consumed
by the rest of the industry so that is
how you define the relationship
cool thank you thank you very much